[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
wir müssen über sexismus reden
willisch wechselt ihr image weg vom
teenie hin zu einer verführerischen frau
und prompt hagelt es hämische kommentare
schluss mit dieser fleischbeschau sagten
sich die deutschen turnerinnen und
trugen bei olympia endlich mehr stoff
und bei den salzburger festspielen trägt
die verführerische botschaft kurzes haar
geht garnicht monierten vor allem männer
wir müssen reden
der hand sicherlich bei sächsischen
schweiz das ist das unter einem begriff
zu fassen wenn es ein präzise mädels
gesellschaft funktioniert schon sehr
stark ruft das größte menschen könnten
später drehte
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz wir sind
zurück aus der sommerpause nehmen sie
mit heute an den rhein und zwar auf
dieses alte schiff aus england das zur
kultur bühne umfunktioniert wurde eine
entdeckung im basler klybeck quartier
wir widmen uns heute dem thema sexismus
und dafür gibt es stoff genug und
manchmal ist es auch zu wenig wird im
juli bei der em als die norwegischen
handballerin mit einer strafe belegt
worden weil sie statt der super knappen
bikinis in etwas mehr stoff tragen
wollten was sie nicht hätten dürfen im
gegensatz dazu gibt es an schweizer
schulen immer hitziger diskussionen was
mädchen in mindesten tragen müssen
beides ist sexismus das findet auch
meine kollegin dino gadient der
neuerdings bei instagram für uns als
host agiert
sexismus ist auch in lenzburg in
stabsstelle geschlecht an die kunden aus
dem volk stellen wir sexistischer eben
diese gesellschaft und wie es ist ich
bin ich selber bin 36 bin journalist
leben der stadt bin schwul und denke
dass sie eigentlich überhaupt nicht
sexistisch bin der hand sicherlich
sächsische schweiz sofern
die funktion würde ich erst mal sagen
das ist die vorherrschaft
heterosexuellen
portion internalisiert sexismus sie uns
das zu sagen dass all das durchzogen sei
von der immer selben struktur namen
sexismus als mir ein bisschen so einfach
zuerst treffe ich melanie weniger und
bin nervös
1996 vize miss schweiz gekürt ich bin
damals zwölf jahre alt und für mich ist
sie seitdem eine art öffentliches
schweizer kulturgut ok kulturgut
auch eine schwierige formulierung
wirklich gehört was können sie für
frauen sind die bilder allerdings
derzeit keine
warum nur der frau will ich sagen es
hat das sportfoto hinter bonnie
& dogs in die augen geschaut oder angst
die männer gehören
wahrscheinlich vor dem ungelöster also
ich meine ich weiß noch gar nicht mehr
gemacht dann hat man eh alexander
schmidt gerne wieder dunkelhäutig bis
melanie weniger schafft das scheinbar
unmögliche gewinnt und verbindet die
krone mit einer gewissen coolness die
tessinerin gilt als stark und
selbstbewusst jetzt kommt ein körper des
goldman sachs
einzigen profitiert eigentlich fuso
gewissen wegen sexistischer wird
vorstellen aber es gibt ich glaub von
der sexistische vorstellung
dass diese fragen nicht mehr gestellt
und ja irgendwo oder sehr wahrscheinlich
so aber das ist meine bewusst gesehen
und im moment wo muss mir bewusst wurde
nicht an ich mich sehr schnell entfernt
und sehr schnell
befreit vor dem ganze wird das kind
überträgt weil man wie üblich so dazu
wie bleibt dann ist mir das tue sie
versucht gegen erinnerungen die
männliche sieht aber brauche statt aber
der ist aber damit man mir hier schon
plan so leider nicht nur visa oder oder
dumm also hat er immer wieder bewiesen
dass ich dumm bin
sexismus das wird mir in diesem moment
bewusst ist ziemlich schwierig zu fassen
ich benutze den begriff ohne genau zu
wissen was er eigentlich meint
sexismus ist immer kontextabhängig
zu verschiedenen zeiten an verschiedenen
orten und in verschiedenen sozialen
räumen meint der begriff
unterschiedliches
in der amerikanischen frauenbewegung der
1960 er jahre wurde er als analogie zu
rassismus eingeführt und sollte ein
unterdrückung verhältnis erstmals
benennbar machen
seit den 1980 er jahren richtet sich die
sexismus kritik besonders gegen die
selbstverständlich vorherrschende
männliche norm in sprache
wissenschaft oder in öffentlichen
institutionen
sexismus hat immer mit macht und
privilegien zu tun die in einer
patriarchalischen gesellschaft menschen
mit dem männlichen geschlecht und der
heterosexualität zu fallen
sexismus funktioniert wie das feuer an
der dynamit stange sobald das wort
formuliert ist explodieren schlagzeilen
bilder dort kommen erinnerungen hoch die
prägen und bleiben auch bei susanne amt
also wenn meine frau später dick werden
würde war ich so an mitte 20 hat irgend
einem freund gesagt von der von der
familie dann würde ich die verlassen
also dass das geht ja gar nicht gebe
frauen irgendwann sich ist ein kleiner
satz aber heute 30 jahre später kann ich
mich daran erinnern also hatte ja
irgendetwas mit mir gemacht als
professorin der universität bayreuth
forscht sie zu sexismus und rassismus in
ihrem buch verknüpft sie historisches
mit aktuellen debatten erzählt die
geschichte einer unterdrückung
viele denken dass es sich bei 6 essen
muss um vergewaltigung handelt oder um
sexuelle nötigung natürlich ist dass
sexismus das ist aber nur die spitze des
eisberges die auch einen riesen system
steht die sowohl durch strukturen durch
moralvorstellungen und so weiter geprägt
sind
sexismus benennt gewalt
benachteiligungen aller art sichtbare
und unsichtbare
sexismus frage ich mich ist das wie ein
label für vieles und ist es gut wenn man
zu haben sagen kann das ist jetzt
sexistisch
nein das ist nicht gut sagt mir wann
sascha vukadinovic hier schreibt für die
konservative zeitschrift schweizer monat
der publizist kritisiert der begriff
meine zu viel unterschiedliches und lade
zur medialen vorverurteilung 1
warum finden sie das ein heikles thema
sexismus dass sex ist das nicht das
einzige thema das heikle thema ist ja
der die aufregung die die miete bewegung
um dem hat also die tendenz zur
selbstjustiz und verselbständigung des
gerüchts und eine plumpe anmache auf der
straße wie beispielsweise beiläufig
passiert ja ist immer noch etwas anderes
als eine vergewaltigung ja und wenn
diese
unterschiedlichen phänomenen
zusammengeführt werden unter einem
begriff hat dann birgt das die gefahr
der trivialisierung ja ich kann das
verstehen ich finde für mich persönlich
sehr sehr wichtig diese oberbegriff zu
haben weil ich der meinung bin es ist
wichtig diese diesen diese diesem
zusammenhang zu verstehen
diskriminierung von frauen und
diskriminierung von homosexuellen und
transgender menschen dass es sozusagen
hat eine gemeinsame wurzeln im rap
gehört der skandal zum konzept und die
grenzüberschreitung zum guten ton über
elf millionen menschen haben sich dieses
deutsch rap video angesehen sexismus
songs wie diese so frauenverachtend was
soll ich sagen ich bin ratlos
sie will in business der machos bestehen
die baslerin lila martini ist zu gast in
einer radioshow und klar auch sie war
schon oft mit sexistischen sprüchen
konfrontiert
ganz schlimm
doch lieber
so explizit
julia martini tritt an gegen das unfaire
und primitiv
das ist gut nur warum sind so viele
sexistische rap songs so erfolgreich
und und einfach akzeptiert wird oder
toleriert wird besser zeit und viele
junge
erstmal man lose die musik irgendwie
auch klappt sie können sich auch sehr
gut mit einem identifizieren bei seiner
art selbstermächtigung geht im alltag
wird diskriminierendes meist nicht hin
gelebt und raus gebrüllt es geht eher um
unterschiede um ungleichheiten
wie sehr war mir bis zum buch von
rebecca händlern nicht bewusst sie
erzählt von autos die nur mit männlichen
dummies am steuer getestet werden das
risiko von frauen bei einem unfall zu
sterben ist um 17 prozent höher
das raumklima am arbeitsplatz ist auf
die menschlichen bedürfnisse
ausgerichtet bürostühle sind denn männer
körper angepasst und auch in der medizin
ist der mann das maß aller dinge die
wahrscheinlichkeit für frauen an einem
herzinfarkt zu sterben ist mehr als
doppelt so hoch als bei männern ein
grund die unkenntnis über weibliche
symptome und medikamente werden viel
seltener frauen getestet die folge ist
falsche dosierung
sexismus beeinflusse unser ganzes dasein
hat mir susanne amt gesagt also wie wir
leben wie wir arbeiten und wie wir uns
zeigen
nicht nur als schönheitskönigin musste
sich melanie winiger wären auch später
als schauspielerin in los angeles zb
gegen nächtliche einladungen aufs
hotelzimmer
gegen wissen es ist es so dass man
damals meeting hw dreharbeiten sehr lang
aber dann kann man es auch in der lobby
und also wenn ich gewusst hätte dass
wenn jetzt das machen dafür irgendwann
komme ich mir das nicht nur wichtig sind
wenn ich einfach genau widerspiegelt
morgen muss angegangen wir hätten es
kommuniziert was sagen sie denn gesagt
ich komme mit dem foto zinner doch
machen gern das meeting am zahn yamaha
weder
logische reaktion sind sagt das meeting
potenzial priester aus was hätte ich tun
muss löste in der ganzen debatte
mit hat sicherlich ausgelöst also
sicherlich gut
der anfang von relais sich zu ärgern das
problem besteht mir wird bewusst ich
spreche mit einer erfolgreichen frau die
in jeder faser ihres berufslebens
erfahrungen mit sexismus gemacht hat der
kamin ort sagen wer kann sagen mir ist
das noch nicht passiert
und das hat mir deutlich gemacht es ist
eine kollektive erfahrung die es
systemisch bedingt die lässt sich nicht
erklären also indem man sagt dass eine
verbindende struktur gibt die
gesellschaften auszeichnen wird ja schon
behauptet ist alle gesellschaften gleich
mit ja und das können sie aber auch gar
nicht sagen aufgrund von historischen
politischen wirtschaftlichen und
kulturellen und religiösen faktoren das
zu sagen dass all das durchzogen sei von
der immer selben struktur namen sexismus
als mir ein bisschen zu einfach
in der ausstellung in lenzburg überlege
ich sexismus nicht strukturen die zahlen
über uns über die schweizer gesellschaft
erzählen von einer anderen wirklichkeit
[Musik]
die opfer häuslicher gewalt sind zu 73
prozent frauen
alleinerziehende sind zu 83 prozent
frauen
wenig optimistisch stimmt mich auch die
zahlen in der kulturbranche in
gruppenausstellungen sind nur ein
drittel künstlerinnen vertreten und bei
einzelausstellungen sinkt ihr wert gar
auf 26 prozent
und noch ist es in der musik
das machen die zahlen einer studie von
pro helvetia deutlich liegt der
frauenanteil bei klassischen konzerten
noch bei 34 prozent sinkt ja im pop und
jazz bei live performances auf nur noch
9 bis 12 prozent
eine frage vielleicht die wichtigste
habe ich noch nicht gestellt deshalb
treffe ich die anti diskriminierungs
expertin die ligna owusu dankbar sie
forscht zu kreieren lebensgemeinschaften
zb in westafrikanischen ghana von ihr
möchte ich wissen warum eigentlich
passiert sexismus normen an den extreme
macht und wenn man dann nicht die norm
post dann dann wird es ganz schnell halt
braucht
auswärtig
und aber warum also wenn ihr
freund an keeper warum passiert das bei
anderen tasten sich
provoziert fühlt oder angriffe das ist
natürlich auch psychologisch
frage ich glaube es hat sehr viel
mit der zweigeschlechtlichkeit
mit der familie namens turbo wie klar
die schweiz angehört und wer nicht und
wenn wenn man ausscheidet
denn dann
stellt das offenbar beruhigt da
die diskussion mit selina wo sehr
dankbar bringt nochmals neue dimensionen
ja gar eine vision will man sexismus
loswerden müssen wir nicht nur unser
familien verständnis überdenken sondern
auch welche arbeit wie viel wert hat
sexismus
ich glaube data domain fertig oder
veränderung zu äußeren beziehung zu
sogenannten reproduktiver arbeit also
care arbeitet
alle arbeiten quasi nicht als produktiv
gehen sondern was auch im hintergrund
muss laufen damit die wichtige gut so
die analytik treten ich glaube dass es
total zum verstopfen und das habe
natürlich aussteller mit
anderen noch einiges vor
[Musik]
letztendlich wenn die erkannten ist mal
da ist das kindliche
haltige oder systems irgendwo als
gesellschaft tief berührt denn dann
glaube ich gibt es einfach kein ort wo
man etr tranche auf das probieren andere
um das doch natürlich fällt sie viel
gras
zivilcourage die auch ich wie alle immer
wieder neu suchen und finden müssen und
es geschieht schon mit bewegungen die
sich formieren und büchern die
erscheinen das lässt mich hoffen auf
eine weniger sexistische welt denn es
wäre eine lebenswerte welt und zwar für
uns alle
[Musik]
kulturplatz findet sie neuerdings auf
instagram und zwar unter anderem mit
tanks märz eine
fernsehsendung
kulturplatz und du hast auch im betrag
mit braucht zum thema sexismus um was
genau es
kunstprojekt unter die lupe genommen
basel und zwar vor zwei studentinnen ist
wichtig sie aufmerksamkeit generieren
für den heimwerker mit noch daheim läuft
kann er mir frauenrollen ganz einfach ja
ich das gefühl also mir gut sicher so
und ich weiß es von denen von mira nach
gut und sie ein wunder dass frauen
einfach so als halbstaatlichen wartet
muss irgendein bis andere und jürgen
weise finde was sie genau für vorstand
und wie sie das projekt stellte
anzusagen und die betrag ist sie jetzt
auf instagram und auch und fernsehen
in der nacht erneut geheime geht vielen
russen völklingen und mehr gut es hat
also ich mag es tut elsasser straße
entlang und fordert mehr schultyp nur
pfiffe und ganz wenn eine frau im inside
aus dass ein auto larissa kurve und alex
entrup und hat ganz projekt haben für
alex
ich bin er ist 21 jahre alt ich bin 24
und mehr hand zusammen raum für alle
grün
blauen für alle haben wir wollen oft
angst und gedanke frau in der nacht
aufmerksam aber leider zu normalität
worden sind und dafür haben wir fünf
frauen und zum nächsten umkreis vertont
und so in der nacht zuvor am hainberg
begleitet unser projekt genauer die
dazugehörige audioaufnahme findet man
auf unserer website bewegung tragen für
alle punkt ch und was ist start hinauf
ins plakat es kommt auf die jeweilige
route ins ziel ist dass wir durch der
georg ruf denn direkt auf unserer
website führt wird denn haben sich doch
eigentlich name für eine frau war und so
direkt durch die frau eine kurze
beschreibung und frau denn darunter
wirklich in 80 das audio lose und tut
dies ablaufen
ich habe im winter
überfall erlaubt auch die anprobe auf
dem velo
und ich glaube der dichte punkt sehe wo
ich selber für mehrweg märkte jetzt kann
ich nicht tatenlos bleiben und mehr
wahrnahm und mir sehr überlegen wo mehr
tore
und das scheint zu sagen jetzt machen
wir bis zum
viel prävention war halt immer man läuft
zielt nicht auf das auch ab sondern ist
völlig auf die werke gab das heißt ich
obwohl ich mich selber nicht in die
situation bringen wo es mit dem
schlüssel in hand highlight für ich muss
meine beste freundin spiegel moniz b mit
warmem xp und und warum nicht mal das
unfreie und ruhige aber was bringt denn
überhaupt uns erst an der prunk und ich
habe das jetzt wirklich im umfeld mehr
das projekt startet haben dass viele
lithium er rosen und mehr wer genau die
vorgestellten hey was kann ich als man
denn eigentlich mache und eine gut
zweistündige kommission darüber aber man
merkt gegenüber will dass man sich wohl
und sicher fühlt oder
was einem mann und ein macher dass das
60 geführt das problem ist so
vielschichtig dass ich nicht glaube mir
nicht glaube dass es eine chance gibt
aber es sei allgemein ist auch haben wir
auf der straße sieht das konkret aus
einfach mal
gehört oder er wollte ja also das
gleichstellungsbüro
hatte kam bei uns gewollte ich glaube
das problem ich wieder stoppt
bekommt aber
spektrums quality fans spannendes thema
vor allem was mit
mega großer teil der bevölkerung
betrifft egal ob es um sexuelle oder alt
die person sich nicht auf der straße
wird dann kommt das gefühl du findest du
auch umsetzung oder eine spüle irgend
etwas konkretes musste gegen acht werde
lasst uns wissen und bis zum nächsten
mal
jetzt haben wir den betrag sei über das
projekt vor basel was braucht es dann
das junge frau zumdick sauber sicherer
fühlen warnt uns noch
tigers prüft die nacht viel glück dass
eine heimelf das ist viel autos hätte
dass er und große straße oder auch dass
ich mit dem velo unterwegs die
hauptmaßnahmen ich kann gar nichts nach
zwei wenig befehl zum langsam was mir
schon heimisch und
jungs cool es müsste ich schon noch
einiges passieren bis zum sparen ich
weiß nicht mal mehr stroosse land
brachen diebe oder lukas ist heller ist
oder ich weiß wirklich nicht was ich
mache und ich glaube das ist schwieriger
wird ein problem jetzt hat seinen basel
einen vergewaltigungsfall gerber vor
gericht reue ist wofür versorgt hat und
was es denkt nachkommen der richtung
gegangen dass der vergewaltigungsfall
jetzt zu einer straff meter groß und
zwar sind vor allem die aussage vom
gerichtssaal wurden für der unmut
gesorgt kann und zwar richtig ein
vergewaltigungsopfer resultat gerechnet
worden dass sie umgehend mit dem feuer
gespielt hätte und sich durch das
mitverantwortlich gemacht hat ja sie hat
mit dem feuer gespielt hatte ein kurzes
röckchen an mit solchen und ähnlichen
aussagen werden opfer sexueller gewalt
oft beschuldigt und theater
reingewaschen genau so einen fall
thematisiert die indische regisseur in
mali katar nature in ihrem neuesten
stück es ist zu sehen am zürcher theater
spektakel das morgen eröffnet wird
theaterzeit am zürichsee das zürcher
theater spektakel bietet wieder
einblicke in unbekannte theaterwelt live
und mit publikum und produktionen die
als livestream zu sehen sind auf online
plattformen
[Musik]
angeli auf deutsch angeblich ist so ein
online theaterprojekt das sich wie ein
brennglas mit dem thema sexueller
übergriffe auseinandersetzt im zentrum
die befragung eines opfer sexueller
gewalt
regisseurin marie catania hat das stück
entwickelt und wird als opfer in einer
art kreuzverhör genommen
[Musik]
ich würde nicht von opfer sprechen ich
nenne sie eine überlebende weil das wort
opfer die person die so etwas durch
litten hat in eine seltsame position von
erniedrigung bringt
da kommt eine art hierarchie ins spiel
wenn wir das wort opfer verwenden
maly cataleya erzählt nicht von einer
der brutalen vergewaltigung die in den
letzten jahren in indien immer wieder
für aufsehen sorgten und zu öffentlichen
protest führt ihre geschichte ist
alltäglicher
sobald es um einen dieser brutalen fälle
geht können sich die leute das publikum
leicht davon distanzieren
sie sagen dann ach das sind die das
geschieht anderen
sie sagen das könnten wir seien es geht
um mich mal
ii catania verarbeiteten ihrem stück
eine persönliche erfahrung die sie sehr
detailliert berichten muss
sie hatten sich beim tanzen
kennengelernt
und flirt
sie besuchen eine party
[Musik]
doch dann sorgt die frau nein zu etwas
was er nicht will klar und eindeutig
nein was vom man ignoriert wird er tut
dir gebracht
es herrscht in solchen fällen allgemeine
atmosphäre tiefen misstrauen man stellt
einer frau die sexuelle gewalt erlebt
hat nicht so viele fragen wie jemandem
der einen diebstahl oder einen mord
begangen hat doch das ist der fall
und das ist die würde das ist das
grundproblem das sind die auswirkungen
des patriarchats
doch das stück belässt es nicht mehr der
schädigung sexueller gewalt ein chor von
unterschiedlichen stimmen kommentiert
die befragung auch das publikum kann
abstimmung hinter aktiv mit ja oder nein
auf fragen wie können die viele
tatsachen seien übertreibt sie hat sie
selbst schuld was wäre gerecht diesen
fragen kann niemand ausweichen noch
männer nicht
ich muss zugeben dass wir für dieses
stück leider kein allzu großes
männliches publikum gefunden haben
das ist nicht überraschend
es ist nicht überraschend denn eines der
probleme der metro bewegung ist dass wir
nie einen weg gefunden haben nicht den
männer zu sprechen
wir fanden viel resonanz untereinander
wir haben uns gegenseitig viele
geschichten erzählt was sehr sehr
notwendig war
wir haben das verhalten der täter
aufgezeigt was dringend notwendig war
aber wir waren bis jetzt nicht in der
lage herauszufinden wie wir mit den
männern darüber sprechen
doch genau dafür bietet dieses stück
gelegenheit weil es fragen steht die
männer nicht loslassen weil es nicht
schwarz-weiß malt sondern in die
alltäglichen zwischen bereiche führt von
sexismus und sexueller gewalt
das stück von marika teenager sehen sie
am 2 september und hier die britische
gerne die läuft am wochenende aus und
bringt ganz viel kulturprogramm mit sich
nächste woche dann nehmen wir sie mit
skulpturen ausstellung in bad ragaz die
ich zusammen mit michael von der heide
besuchen werde und gleich jetzt geht es
weiter mit dem staatsanwalt kommen sie
gut durch die woche schiff ahoi
[Musik]